Last time we talked about Kirksey versus Kirksey,
where the court deemed a promise Amir gratuity because the promise lacked
consideration.
Today we will continue to discuss consideration this time we'll examine Langer
versus superior steel corporation,
a case that is explicitly distinguished from Kirksey and which presents an
interesting transition case in the understanding of consideration.
In discussing Langer will also revisit the concept of promissory Estoppel,
which we saw earlier in the introductory case rickets versus scar thorn.
The langor case was decided by the Pennsylvania Superior Court in 1932 first,
let's quickly recap Kirksey versus Kirksey.
There we saw a gratuitous promise is not an enforceable contract because
contracts require consideration.
Moreover,
a detriment caused by the uh,
promises reliance on the promise does not itself constitute consideration if
it's not bargained for.
In this case,
the Superior Steel Corporation determined to replace Langer,
the plaintiff,
his foreman of one of its departments.
Langhart had worked for the company for over 30 years.
Langer received a letter from the company.
The letter stated that the company would pay him a pension of $100 per month as
long as the plaintiff preserved his present attitude of loyalty to the company
and its officers and was not employed in any competitive occupation.
The plaintiff did not go to work for a competitor and superior steel made the
pension payments described in the letter around four years later,
however,
the company stopped making the payments.
So the plaintiff sued for enforcement of the terms of the letter.
The trial court found in favor of the company on dimmer that sustaining
questions of law the company had raised,
uh,
but the instant court reversed and remanded the case for a new trial.
The issue is this was the companies promise to pay supported by consideration.
Well,
by now we know that enforceable contract requires consideration.
How should a court determine whether there's consideration?
Kirksey did not offer much guidance on this and on this question it was just a
three sentence opinion.
So let's compare some definitions.
The restatement of contracts first,
which was published the same year and indeed within the same week says the
opinion issued in Langer defined consideration in section 75 as and action other
than a promise or a forbearance or the creation,
modification or destruction of a legal relationship or return promise bargained
for and given in exchange for the promise.
An interesting example,
it was a of consideration is given in the comments a promises be $500 when be
goes to college.
This can be understood in a couple of ways.
Say a mother really wants her rebellious teenage son to go to college,
but her son doesn't want to plan on doing so.
In that scenario,
the mother's promise to pay is supported by consideration.
She's bargaining for the sun to go to college,
but what if a mother assumes her son is going to college and treats the
departure of her college?
Is a kin to say an 18th birthday and occasion for celebration,
not for bargaining.
If the promise isn't made as an agreed exchange for our son's going to college,
but as a conditional gift payable on his departure.
This wouldn't be consideration for a promise.
The first restatements definition might seem counter to the result we saw in
Kirksey.
The plaintiff's abandoning her and her land and moving to her brother in law's
seemed at first to fit it,
but comments see to this section states in part that quote the fact that the
promise he relies on the promise to his injury or the promise or gain some
advantage there from does not establish consideration without the element of
bargain or agreed exchange.
Now consider section 71 of the restatement of contracts second published in 1981
it states that to constitute consideration of performance or return promise must
be bargained for.
We've been emphasizing this before and the text then explains that to be
bargained for a performance or return promise is have must be sought by the
promise or in exchange for his promise and is given by the promise in exchange
for that promise.
This is also referred to as the inducement requirement that one quid induces the
quo and the CWO induces the quid comment.
P B of this section further elaborates on bargaining,
noting that in the typical bargain,
the consideration and the promise bear reciprocal relation of motive or
inducement,
that consideration induces the making of the promise and the promise induces the
furnishing of the consideration.
But it's not enough that the promise induces the conduct of the promise.
See,
or that the conduct of the promising induces the making the promise both
elements must be present or there is no bargain.
So says the comment to restatement second.
Now,
how did the court explained consideration in the Langer opinion?
Well,
the court sided Wilson who wrote a famous treatise on contracts and it was a
member of the committee creating the 1932 restatement of contracts.
Willison offered a helpful,
although not conclusive tests for determining whether a condition included in an
offer constituted consideration for the offer or was quote,
a mirror condition in a gratuitous promise unquote,
if the currents of the condition would benefit the promise or it could be fairly
inferred that the currents of the condition was requested as consideration.
In other words,
the fact that the condition would benefit the promise promise or suggest that
the promised or his promise was meant to induce the promises,
conduct applying this test to the condition and superior steel,
uh,
that Langer quote,
preserve his attitude of loyalty to the company and its officers and not be
employed in any competitive co,
uh,
occupation.
The court found that this would benefit the company and so suggested that it
constituted sufficient consideration.
Now,
let's consider by contrast,
Kirksey versus Kirksey,
which the court distinguished from langurs case.
Remember that in Kirksey,
a widow received a letter like in Langer,
uh,
but this time from her late husband's brother advising there to sell our land
and telling her that if she came to where he lived,
he would put her up in a home and let her have a place to raise her children
because,
uh,
he wanted her and her children to do well.
The widow did move and abandoned her land and her brother-in-law put her up for
a couple of years,
but afterward requested her to leave the three Supreme Court of Alabama to
determine that there was no consideration and that the defendant's offer was a
mere gratuitous promise.
Would the condition and the brother in law's offer survive?
Willis [inaudible] benefit test?
Well,
no,
the Kirksey court found it hard to see how the brother in law was benefited by
her coming to live where he lived.
But if you go back to the module we just had on Kirksey versus Kirksey,
there is new history that suggests that maybe it could have even survived the
benefit test that Willis didn't propose,
that maybe there was actually a hidden benefit.
Uh,
uh,
for this brother in law,
in having her move to his land.
But another way of thinking about a inducement is to ask whether the parties
contemplated mutuality of obligation.
That is whether they believe both parties were going to be bound to perform
their obligations.
If Langer believed he was obligated to refrain from what he otherwise could do
work for a competitor company,
then we might infer that there was a bargain for exchange and not merely a
conditional gift.
If I say to you,
I'll give you my old coat.
If you come to buy my house to pick it up and you say,
okay,
neither of us thinks that you'll be in breach of contract if you fail to come by
and pick it up.
But the parties might have believed that Langer would be in breach if he went to
work for a competitor.
Though the court found that the companies promise was supported by consideration
so as to create an enforceable contract.
The court proposed alternative reasoning by which to enforce the steel companies
promise.
This was the theory of promissory Estoppel,
which we discussed earlier in rickets versus thorn.
A case which the Langer court cited as well.
In addition to siting records,
the court quoted section 90 of the first restatement of contracts which said a
promise which the promise or should reasonably expect to induce action or
forbearance of a definite and substantial character on the part of the primacy
in which does into such action or forbearance is binding if injustice can be
avoided only by enforcement of the promise.
Is the theory of promissory Estoppel and alternative convincing basis for
adverse for enforcing the terms of the steel companies letter?
Well,
probably yes.
Uh,
but remedy the remedy might be limited to what justice demands.
What about in Kirksey versus Kirksey with the logic of promissory Estoppel have
made sense in that case?
Again,
the answer is yes,
but as we discussed in the earlier module,
it hadn't been developed then.
So what have we learned?
We see that even minor requested performance,
which includes refraining from doing something,
can constitute consideration whether the port performance is great,
uh,
is far less significant to question than whether the performance is bargained
for.
We also learned,
importantly that Wilson's benefit tests provides a useful means for evaluating
and identifying whether a good given condition was bargained for,
or merely a gratuitous condition.
Uh,
uh,
provision.
And finally,
we saw that promissory Estoppel is a potential alternative grounds for
enforcement.